[Music]
on this wednesday night growing
irritation over canada's slow
vaccination campaign
the calls to hurry up already it's
ridiculous
why thousands of appointments have been
cancelled plus the amplifying demands
for accountability
the risks of being complacent instead of
compliant
people need to stay strong and just hold
on to the rules just a little bit longer
a 22 year old canadian survivor of the
variant
tells us what he endured afghanistan
alone again
as the u.s plans to completely withdraw
its forces where does it leave the
country
and canada's legacy there plus 100 days
to the tokyo olympics
yes it's going to be different how
canadian athletes are preparing
for the pandemic games
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
this has been a long slog for all of us
and we're still at a precarious point in
the pandemic
the seven day average of new coven cases
in canada is almost on par with the peak
of the second wave back in january there
now are an average of 8 000 new cases
being reported
every day hospitalizations which always
lag behind the new cases are
also rapidly rising they've increased 29
percent
over last week the highly transmissible
variance of concern
are driving this vaccines will stop it
but
only two percent of the population is
fully protected with both
vaccine doses now more than 20 percent
of canadians have now received at least
one vaccine dose ontario has
administered the most doses yesterday it
set a daily record
more than 112 000 shots in arms
the demand is there and yet thousands of
ontarians have had their vaccine
appointments
cancelled abigail beeman explains why in
our top story tonight
frustrated angry one word
pissed marie is one of ten thousand
people in an eastern toronto
neighborhood with a vaccine appointment
canceled the numbers are going up you
want us to be vaccinated
and you're running out of vaccine
everywhere you go
a number of sites forced to cancel
bookings including in hard hit
scarborough
it's really frustrating there needed to
be sort of a
oversight and a redistribution of
vaccine from the areas that are
lower risk have less coveted incidents
to the areas that our hardest hits
ontario's premier says delays from
moderna
as well as astrazeneca have caused a
logistical nightmare
it's not about pointing fingers at any
level of government as i said
the facts are we are short on the supply
alberta is faster to point fingers at
ottawa responsible for procurement
jurisdictions around the world that
produce no vaccines
starting with israel have now achieved
effective immunity in their population
opposition parties on parliament hill
piled on other countries are reopening
mr speaker
we're going back into lockdown there are
zoo animals that are being vaccinated in
the united states
well quebec is reporting a wave of
femicides because women are locked down
with their abusers
canadians are angry and they want to
know how the prime minister let things
get so bad we recognize that things are
getting very bad particularly in ontario
and that's why we are continuing to be
there
to support the ford government not fast
enough to protect madiha khan's 67 year
old mother whose appointment was
canceled
looking forward to it because it was it
meant that she would
get vaccinated go back to school and
work with the special needs unmasked
kids but protect it particularly
frustrating for that family and
others reports of vaccines sitting in
freezers
distribution is a provincial
responsibility here in ontario the
province attributes those stored doses
to a buffer public health units keep on
hand in case of future delays
officials would only say it's a few days
worth but as the province tries to blame
cancellations in hot spots on shortage
issues experts say that doesn't square
with vaccines
in freezers abigail beeman global news
ottawa
adding to the frustration is the
emerging information about a rare kind
of blood clotting
occurring in some people after they get
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine and in
the u.s
the johnson and johnson vaccine today
health canada said it is not restricting
the use of the astrazeneca vaccine after
a thorough review of data from europe
and the uk
at the same time though the national
advisory committee on immunization
recommends astrazeneca not be given to
people under the age of 55.
canada's chief medical advisor dr
supriya sharma says there is a stronger
link between
adverse reactions and the vaccine but
the risk of blood clots is still very
low
for all of the age groups especially
when we're in the situation
where the risk of covet is moderate or
high as it is in many parts of the
country
the benefits of the astrazeneca vaccine
far away the risks in all age groups
health canada is changing the labeling
on the vaccine to include a warning
about side effects
the national advisory committee on
immunization will be meeting again to
discuss the real world data that's
emerging about blood clots
and decide whether to adjust their
advice about astrazeneca
denmark denmark is completely pulling
the plug on astrazeneca it has become
the first country in the world to stop
using it all together
astrazeneca shots were put on hold last
month in denmark after reports of rare
forms of blood clotting
despite recommendations from the world
health organization and the european
medicines watchdog to continue with it
denmark says it will not resume using it
it has about 200 000 doses of
astrazeneca in storage which expire in
june
denmark has also put the johnson and
johnson vaccine on pause
also because of reports of blood clots
while hospitals in canada were already
operating at near or over capacity
before the pandemic
kovid has pushed some of them to the
brink in ontario especially in toronto
there have never been this many people
in intensive care at the same time
there are not enough beds and not enough
trained staff and because the virus is
still spreading it's going to get worse
before it gets better eric sorenson
reports
toronto's humber river intensive care
unit is in one of the country's most
advanced pandemic response health care
centers
and it cannot keep up with the influx of
covid patients
raman rai manages the icu here we're
definitely over capacity
we do have staffing shortages so
the team is working really hard and
trying to support
the care for the patients that are
coming in patients who are younger
and who are sicker humber river has been
forced to transfer some patients to
other hospitals
and staffing at many hospitals is barely
holding up
nurses at the point of exhaustion i'll
tell you
we're stretched we're really stressed
and i'm very concerned about what the
next
not only a few days but weeks will bring
the waves of the covid pandemic can be
seen in hospitalizations and in icu
cases
the previous peak in mid-january saw
1700 hospitalized in ontario
and 400 seriously ill in icus
the third wave has come with even more
force hospitalizations reaching 1877
today
and icu cases have more than doubled in
the last month
to stand at 642 and this wave has not
crested yet but the complex environment
of an icu
cannot be expanded instantly and neither
can staff
be trained overnight to bring nurses who
haven't worked in icu
into our icus is really very very
difficult
chio the children's hospital in ottawa
has joined sick kids in toronto in
creating space for adults in need of
critical care
but specialized staff remains a
challenge you can have like
a million ventilators that won't help
you if you don't have the trained
specialized nurses physicians
respiratory therapists and other staff
to operate them work to build a new
field hospital is expected to begin in
hamilton within days but it will not be
ready for some time
and those supporting the front line work
say they cannot see the end in sight
every day is a challenge and it's trying
to manage the flow
into the unit trying to figure out how
we're going to be able to provide care
to all these patients
frontline workers need reinforcements
and they need a break
but the vast majority keep coming back
for their next shift
eric sorensen global news toronto
we have reported for months on the rise
of the variance of concern they are
still covered 19 but they spread
so much faster it's like a whole new
pandemic requiring
even more vigilance to keep from getting
infected even if you are young and think
you are
invincible jackson proskow reports
my body felt like it was running a
marathon every day
after eight days in a winnipeg hospital
22 year old peter solomon is still
recovering
after contracting the so-called uk
variant
both of his parents ended up in hospital
with it too
with the variance i don't think young
people are protected at all i think
everyone is kind of at risk at the
moment more than a year into the
pandemic
virus variants have changed what we
thought we knew about covid
because of how easily they spread that
trip to the grocery store a front line
job or
indoor dining are now riskier than at
any point before
these more contagious variants do mean
that smaller
interactions smaller breeches in your
protocols of social distancing and
wearing masks
do matter and yet many of our
precautions have remained the same
a focus on cleaning surfaces instead of
ventilation
for a virus that's airborne and too many
people still wearing masks that no
longer measure up
what we're seeing is a more dangerous
form of covet
dr tom frieden is the former director of
the u.s centers for disease control
he warns now is the time to double down
on precautions
and stay outdoors he even recommends
upgrading to
higher quality masks like n95s where
available
if you have a high risk individual who
is not vaccinated
who has to go into a crowded space
then i would want that person to be
wearing a better mask
not only do the variants pose a greater
risk across all age groups
but their rapid spread increases the
chances of more viral mutations
even as vaccinations ramp up the longer
we let the virus
circulate in the population the more
chances it has
to mutate evolve and present us with new
challenges
at a time when the pandemic feels like
it should be over
we're being urged to think of a now
familiar virus in a whole new way
the message needs to go out there that
people need to kind of
stay strong and just hold on to the
rules just a little bit longer
jackson prosco global news washington
british columbia has reached a somber
milestone in another health crisis one
that existed
long before covet it's been five years
since the province declared the opioid
crisis
a public health emergency since then
more than 7 000 people have died by
overdose an average of five people are
dying by overdose every day in bc now
2020 was the deadliest year on record
1724 lives
lost and so far 2021 is shaping up to be
even worse
we need to be open about it we need to
recognize that this is a
problem of the human condition and that
we can't be judgmental
we need to show our compassion to
everybody
who is using drugs to help support them
through this
today the province announced it will
formally request federal exemption from
health canada if approved
bc would become the first province in
the country to decriminalize the
personal possession
of illicit drugs alberta has become the
latest province to sign onto a deal to
explore small
nuclear reactor technology i'm glad that
we're now
in this group to work together to find a
canadian solution
that can be a real game changer for
power production
premier jason kenney along with his
counterparts in ontario saskatchewan and
new brunswick held a virtual signing
today
all four provinces oppose the federal
carbon tax and they believe
small modular nuclear reactors can be
used to meet regional energy needs and
fight climate change canada's first grid
scale nuclear reactor project is
expected to be in place in ontario by
2028. oh we know zoom calls are part of
everyday life for many people now
that means the camera can potentially
always be on
this happened during a parliamentary
zoom call among mps today a colleague
snapped the photo during question
period we blurred part of it it's
liberal mp william amos
minus his clothes the speaker reminded
mps to be aware when they are near a
camera
and amos issued this statement
afterwards this is an unfortunate error
he says my video was accidentally turned
on as i was changing into my work
clothes after going for a jog
i sincerely apologize to my colleagues
in the house of commons for this
unintentional distraction obviously he
says it was an honest mistake
and it won't happen again uncertainty
looms over
afghanistan coming up the precarious
path forward without american troops
plus the charges against the white
minnesota police officer who shot and
killed dante wright
and emergency off louisiana the search
for people missing
from a capsized ship
the united states is leaving afghanistan
president biden has vowed to withdraw
all u.s forces by september 11th
20 years after the first americans
arrived to drive out al qaeda
and end taliban rule i've concluded that
it's time to
end america's longest war it's time for
american troops to come home
canada joined the international
coalition in afghanistan in 2001 and our
troops were stationed there until 2014
159 canadian soldiers died during the
war in afghanistan
more than 2200 u.s troops lost their
lives
and the vast majority of people who died
there are civilians it's estimated
over 100 000 afghans have been killed
more than 26 000 or about one-quarter of
those
are children although the taliban were
removed from powder
power and the al-qaeda network was
disrupted canada and its allies failed
to destroy
either group or to secure and stabilize
the entire country
now without the umbrella of u.s
protection uncertainty again
hangs over the future of afghanistan
mike armstrong
reports on the streets of the afghan
capital
mixed emotions news the u.s is pulling
out is welcomed by some
criticized by others but many on both
sides agree the stability they'd hoped
for
hasn't come foreign forces this man says
failed to fulfill the promises they made
to the afghan people
now the original goal of the afghan
mission wasn't as broad as it would
become
within weeks of the 9 11 attacks the u.s
canada and other nato countries were in
afghanistan the aim to go after al qaeda
and the group that had given its safe
haven the taliban
but along the way the goal posts moved
it became a question of nation-building
turning afghanistan into a stable
democracy
we don't bring that canadian veteran
brian mckenna calls it
mission creep sending an army isn't
going to fix your roads balance your
judiciary
make sure that taxes are collected
after close to two decades the situation
in afghanistan is
delicate government forces control most
of the major cities but taliban forces
are strong in the regions about half the
countries contested
while completely destroying the taliban
mckenna says
is probably never going to happen ideas
don't surrender
right people do what may be hard to
remember
is what afghanistan was before coalition
forces went in
men were killed for not having beards
people were stoned for listening to
music
and soccer stadiums were turned into
exhibition grounds for public beheadings
afghanistan is much better today than it
was in the 1990s there's no doubt about
it at all
especially if you're a woman especially
if you're a minority
and frankly for the quality of life in
general despite the violence being so
severe
the question is where things go from
here there have been peace talks ongoing
since september between the government
and the taliban
there was supposed to be another round
10 days starting this coming weekend in
turkey
a taliban spokesperson has now said
their side is pulling out
until all foreign troops leave
afghanistan
president biden said wednesday diplomacy
shouldn't depend on boots on the ground
but
having those boots preparing to leave
may already be changing
the balance of power mike armstrong
global news
still ahead the horrific scene in niger
after a fire
tore through an elementary school
the white police officer who fatally
shot a 20-year-old unarmed black man
during a traffic stop in minnesota has
been charged with second-degree
manslaughter
kim potter fired the shot that killed
dante wright on sunday she was a 26-year
veteran of the brooklyn center police
department
on tuesday she resigned along with the
police chief the chief had
said potter mistakenly grabbed her gun
instead of her taser
every night since his death protesters
have taken to the streets angry
about yet another police shooting of an
unarmed black man
the man who orchestrated the biggest
financial fraud in u.s
history has died bernie madoff died
early this morning in a federal prison
in north carolina
for more than 50 years he was famous on
wall street as a big
money manager and then in 2008 his ponzi
scheme
came crashing down madoff swindled
thousands of investors out of an
estimated 65 billion dollars his
official cause of death has not been
released but he had been receiving
treatment for terminal kidney disease
he was 82 years old
a desperate search is underway off the
coast of louisiana tonight after a
commercial
ship capsized the 39 meter vessel
snapped in a storm late tuesday
the body of one person was pulled from
the water six other people were rescued
but it's believed 12 others are still
missing the u.s coast guard is leading
the search with help from other private
vessels in the area
it's not known why the boat capsized but
there were high winds in the area
when it went down people in the capital
of niger are mourning the deaths of 20
children after a devastating fire at an
elementary school
rows of burnt desks and chairs are all
that remain the flames broke out during
classes and authorities say
high winds fanned the flames spreading
them through the school
about 2 000 children attend classes
there investigators are working to
determine what caused the fire
it has highlighted the danger of
temporary classrooms
straw huts are often set up to make room
for students at overcrowded schools
[Music]
final countdown next canada's top
athletes prepare for tokyo's olympics
there's usually such a big buildup to
the summer olympics but this year things
are much
more muted the tokyo olympics already
postponed by year
start in just 100 days and for athletes
their families and for sports fans
this is going to be an olympics like no
other mike trolley
explains it's fair to say the road to
the tokyo olympics is lacking its usual
punch remember the torch run leading up
to vancouver
in japan a surge in kova 19 cases has
pushed runners
off public roads to make up for the lost
energy
they danced once the games begin there
will be some spectators in the stands
but they won't be allowed to cheer
kayaker maddie schmidt says
in a way they train for that during
olympic qualifications
we didn't have spectators there either
so we finished the race and it was like
a little golf clap
and it was so anticlimactic so if it's
if it's anything more than that i think
we're gonna be pretty used to it
what will be harder for athletes to
process is the isolation
as japan has said only members of team
canada can enter the country
family and friends have to stay at home
thank gosh
for you know live streaming and
face time and watch that video and zoom
like i feel like that lack of support
will not be there we know everyone's
still backing us even though they're not
in tokyo with us
but i know for me knowing that my family
and my canoe club and same with maddie
and andrea
watching back home like just thinking
about that
is is is really helpful and motivation
the olympics aren't popular right now in
japan they have bigger worries with kova
19
and a shortage of vaccines that will be
a distraction
but these are focused olympic athletes
if anything it's almost more special
that we've been able to overcome all the
obstacles to get to where we will get to
so
yeah i refuse to to settle for anything
less than that olympic glory feeling
even though it's going to be quite
different
mike relay global news toronto and that
is global national for this wednesday
i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is grand bank on
the buren peninsula in newfoundland and
labrador
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
you